and now we begin the business of
tonight's awards I knew there was some
reason we were here present the first of
them here are an actor and an actress
who are extraordinary talents the
radiant Mary Tyler Moore and Oscar
winner Timothy Hutton
Best Performance by an actor in a
supporting role and it's non er to
present this award this year's nominees
are Charles Durning in to be or not to
be
John Lithgow in terms of endearment
Jack Nicholson in terms of in variable
Sam Shepard in the right stuff
Rip Torn in Cross Creek
the winner is Jack Nicholson
and thanks to the members of the Academy
for this wonderful honor congratulations
to John and Sam and the Charles and ripp
for your wonderful jobs it's nice when
you the producer and the director and
the writers are all one man Jim Brooks
he did everything for us on terms of
endearment including writing 11 versions
of this speech I I was going to say a
lot about how much Shirley and Deborah
inspired me but I understand they're
planning an interpretive dance number
later right after the Best Actress Award
explain everything about life and I want
to thank mr. Diller Hyde a shorty in the
rain my age and sandy Bressler all you
rock people down at the Roxy up in the
Rockies rock on Thanks